not mine mine's outside but this is in
case i ever get a dog
[Music]
it's like it's like a it's a smaller
size
hey guys it's david dobrik and these are
my essentials
this right here is extremely important
to me it's a charging case i know this
is really really lame but i have a
method behind it
i have two i like having two chargers
because while i'm out and about with one
the other one is sitting at home and on
the charger and then i can come home
and switch them so i'm never ever
sitting at the charger i hate
having my phone at the charger because
obviously i can't use it and it's just a
pain to plug in at night because i can't
see where the little connector is i've
got to stop doing these motions
i literally do it in every video this is
the honest truth
my phone hasn't died no i actually died
yesterday but before then it hasn't died
in like
in like three months i think because i'm
like i'm on this charging system
and when i travel i have one on my phone
and two in my bag
so i'm ready if you know if something
happens i'm stuck in the middle of the
ocean
i'll have charge for at least 17 hours
this is my next essential
this is my suave kid shampoo now this is
a very particular one
i've just recently switched over to it's
a three in one so it's shampoo
conditioner and body wash
i started using these believe it or not
when i was younger
and i just haven't been able to give
this up for some reason
these are also great i'm like super
hyped on these
these are also great because on the back
there's always
a fact on the back of them this one
doesn't have it because it's a three in
one
so i think they like they omit the fact
because they have so many other things
in it already that there's no need for
the fun fact
but um but sometimes it will teach you
about like a walrus
or like a sea lion um so i've been
learning a lot of facts from this
it's like honestly a learning tool
you're going to be watching this vlog
this guy is a [ __ ] idiot and it
washes your entire body
like you do three squirts on the head
and then you do two a little on the body
and then it all kind of rolls down like
a car wash like a big steam roll over
your body because it's three in one so
it's
you know it's applying everything at
once and then you're clean and it just
washes right off your toes and it's done
deal
it saves time and product space so out
kids
my next item is gum gum is super super
important to me
i have a drawer just dedicated to gum i
can't have conversations with people
without chewing gum like i hate being
close to people
now i'm a little like a little more
lenient on not chewing gum because of
the face mask so i don't feel like i'm
like
spewing my breath at people and i just
always i don't it's not that i don't
brush my teeth i do
but i just like after i brush it like
you still need something in there that's
still working at the same time you're
talking
spearmint is my favorite polar ice not
my favorite it's kind of only here to
show you guys the different options
peppermint's good but if you're gonna go
peppermint might as well go all out and
do spearmint and i just like the color
of green
it catches your eye and it goes whoa
what is what is in that guy's mouth i
want to talk to him
and one thing i do hate is cinnamon gum
oh my god it is the most disgusting gum
i've ever had
that's obviously why it's not here and
it's not allowed in this house
oh [ __ ] did you guys say you want to see
my gum trick okay
hope you're ready for this one
oh i did it oh my god i'm never gonna
have my first drive
that's my favorite gum trick wow that
makes me feel good
this is my disposable camera this is
really really important to me
i just started taking disposable
pictures like two years ago um i have an
instagram account kind of dedicated to
them i really like these
because they're so not aggressive like
you can go into a premiere you can go
into
like any event and you can take pictures
of anybody and no one expects
anything because it's just like i look
like a 20 year old kid with like
this cheap camera but the pictures turn
out amazing this is my sexy friend jeff
with his sexy friend stas and kelsey
this is me flipping the camera off this
is julia and leonardo dicaprio at the
once upon a time in hollywood premiere
they weren't looking at my camera but i
stood right next to the camera guy and i
quickly snapped this
this is benny drawing on my face um for
a juice world music video this is margot
robbie i
asked her if i could take a picture and
she literally goes
uh okay cuz she thought this was so
pathetic it's my favorite john stamos
he's beautiful and then you have kendall
and kylie deciding the same party this
is kylie eating a slice of pizza
cheese get it and then this is um
this is paris hilton paris hilton by the
way is the sweetest person
on planet earth the best part about this
is you can like really live in the
moment i know it sounds so cliche
but it's nice to take a picture and not
look at it and not have to take 50 other
pictures and i even started an app
it's called david's disposable and on
the app you take one picture and
you don't get to see the pictures until
nine am in the next morning
this one's important this is my elon
musk not a flamethrower
it's pretty nice right now it's on low
flame
this is perfect for like when you're
roasting s'mores and this is perfect for
when you hate your neighbors
so it has like it has a little bit of
both this has really gotten me
like through a lot i absolutely
absolutely love it now the next one
this is my new perfume it's called
david's perfume i know and the name's
not crazy
but it did take us a while to come up
with it there's two different scents
this one's amber and cashmere and this
one's grapefruit and sandalwood
they're both unexpected but elegant it's
like the
what we use to describe it and we just
designed the boxes and it's really cool
because it it like opens up um just like
an iphone box which fun fact
i read somewhere that apple the way they
design their boxes it opens faster and
faster the higher you get
it like matches with your heart rate of
you opening the box for the first time
this i don't think we matched with
anybody's heart rate but it is a cool
box
it's coming out this september i think
and it's available at david's perfume
dot com this isn't the finished one
that's why it's like falling apart
it's all fake here none of this is real
this isn't actually my house it's just a
green screen
heck yeah these are important this is
where someone like watches the video and
they just
like exploit out of it i love waters
more than more than
more than any of your friends i think
currently i drink about five liters of
water a day
if you were to do bottles it'd be it'd
be like 10 of these a day
i'm literally a fish and my temperature
preference for water since you guys
asked
is um definitely room temperature even
sometimes warmer than room temperature
like if it's sitting in the garage on a
hot day that's all me it has my name on
it
now the other most important part about
your life is
sleep i think it's so important to have
like a comfy pillow because
you spend like what forty percent of
your life in bed thirty percent of your
life in bed
so this is my favorite it's a bamboo
pillow
it's a little pricey it was fifteen
thousand dollars
um so it's a lot i'm totally kidding
everybody's face in here was like
okay i think it's like 40 dollars i
think it's like 35
it's actually a very like affordable
pillow it's the perfect amount of soft
and firmness and when you flip it over
to the cold side of the pillow like
everybody loves it's like really cold
it's like the perfect amount monocle
it's actually the
only thing i like cold i'm a side
sleeper
so this i you know the side of my face
is on here and then i put a softer
pillow
that's like a little bit longer it's
almost like a body pillow in between my
legs i have to have something in between
my legs
sounds weird sounds really weird this is
really important to me i'm just showing
off
let's keep them coming these are my
favorite awards this is my kids choice
award and this is my people's choice
award
i'm a huge fan of nickelodeon and like i
used to watch kid choice awards
and josh peck got to present me with my
first good short story which is crazy
i was also slimed at this award show
which was really fun i was told it
tastes like green apple
um but it doesn't so that was a serious
letdown these are really cool
because i technically only won one of
these but when you're at the show
right when you win they hand you an
award that's not yours yet
because you get your actual award that
they engrave your name into like months
later like it comes in the mail but they
gave me one just to hold on camera and i
was like yeah when i was so excited and
then i left
like right away immediately booked it
for the door so now i have two they
haven't asked for this one back it makes
no sense i just don't think they care
actually i don't put that in because now
they're gonna be like oh we do care
we're gonna send a swat team to my house
this one's cool because it's a
kaleidoscope and you can look through
the back
and it's like a proper kaleidoscope and
then these
are so incredibly heavy look at this
look at this
like crack my table it's perfect for
when somebody robs me
and now i have two of these one deserved
and one knot
i love awards so much and i all i
honestly think they're kind of pointless
like it's kind of weird that people
decide what is great and what's not so
i'm just i've just been making my own
awards
tick tock of the month top content
creator this is like not a real thing
biggest heart award
the nicest tush award this one's nice
this one's heavy just like the people's
choice award these are comparable
my next thing that i like this is my
natalie
honestly one of the only models out this
is the only matter one of one
one of one natalie's my assistant slash
friend
slash high school homie um we dated back
in high school
we didn't always tell people we didn't
we did not date are you sure
we went to dance together insert pic
natalie asked me
believe it or not even though i looked
like that i think she was like really
desperate in high school
you were literally my last resort i was
her last choice
but to be honest like that was after i
made a public announcement that i was
not going to the dance
so i already i already eliminated all my
options and then since natalie was my
friend i was like you know what i'll
come out of retirement
and i will come and join you at the
turnabout our favorite part
of working together non-stop fun oh what
the hell
my best friends for the next item i'd
like to keep natalie here it's a little
surprise for you i can smell it already
it's deep dish
now this is really important to the both
of us because we're both from chicago
this is from geno's east it's literally
from chicago we flew it in
we didn't fly it in but they just opened
one here wow
little table for mice wow that is crazy
it's like a commercial
oh my god i'm sorry i forgot we're doing
a video shoot it's not even really like
you're having
oh no the cheese fell off you know
sometimes you get moments like this
deepest is the best because it's not
even really like pizza it's kind of just
like it's
like a whole new thing like pizza pie
it's like pizza pie
this is my next favorite thing it's my
tesla
you get one of these when you refer i
think when you refer two people
to buying a tesla this one's this one's
pretty quick this one can
top speed eight miles per hour
acceleration zero to four
in 65 seconds it has a horn
i gotta take it into the shop oh it's
not on
it this is my other favorite thing is um
i just love black clothing like i'm
obsessed with it i started wearing it
because
i would sweat a lot under my armpits and
then i switched over to black and you
never ever see it it was like a cheat
code but now i don't sweat under my
armpits now because i'm not like
like thinking about it constantly and
i'm like oh my god i hope i don't have
pit stains so
it kind of cured me of my sweaty armpits
so i owe a lot to black
my entire closet's flat hold on look
just so i'm not cheating look at this i
just grabbed a handful
and it's just all black t-shirts it's so
much easier
to wear black because it's like one less
decision you have to make every day
look at this that's so cool and they're
slimming so you either hit the gym or
you start wearing black
it's pretty much a win-win it's like i'm
being cuddled all these shirts are
different i really do my favorite shirt
is just like a plain black tee
but sometimes i'll spice it up and i'll
have like a crazy logo on it like this
like that's not or sometimes i'll go
buttons
i'm really unstoppable i have two
buttons
for saturday and sunday sometimes my
shoes will have a little bit of color
that's where i like to mix it up and
then sometimes i'll wear a blue hat
thank you for watching gq we'll see you
later